[Applaudissements]
tous quand ils veulent voilà la semaine
donc on revient dans les gars c'est fait
j'ai mis mes mains ou demain si le
peuple demain on est la découverte à
voyages sncf.com et ça c'est fait j'ai
encore vu des petits trucs vous les
voulez bien sûr que les voeux vous fais
un bisou et l'a51 et surtout qu emma
nouvelle démarche pour las vegas homme
doux
ouais j'ai marché comme ça pour être au
rendez vous c'est pas mal ça américain
et lâcher comme ça faut pas partir les
amerloques
alors on veut du hamburger on va leur
parler en anglais on dit comment nous a
dit huang kandahar car je voudrais
placer déjà grand bravo pour la semaine
des as sur tf1 et qu'est ce que tu as
tourné marié d'y aller de soi est marié
pour l'instant tu touches à ton cul tu
aura certainement là vient il à qui
celui-là il s'est réduit comme gérard
bon je disais quoi oui je parlais des
mines et là je voudrais féliciter sa
styliste